max five and three career against tampa
bay
yeah last starts september second at
philly received the three to two loss
and that's it for the first inning max
grunts
strikes him out on three 61st
strikeout of the year and the rays will
strain the couple that's charlie
morton's
making a second start since coming off
the il last time out against the yankees
two innings
from his wind up he delivers to eaton
curveball half swing and a miss
and wow you talk about making a good
quality veteran hitter look
horrendous at the plate that swing by
adam eaton
who was the result of a wicked curveball
by morton
they want a ground ball from carter
kibum who needs to elevate something
for his seventh rbi here that's a
slow grounder they're going to try to
turn it
and it's safe to call it first and
immediately g-man choi points to his
dugout
says we got to have a look at that this
will tell you it's a great shot right
here
looks safe there and they're not going
to challenge one nothing that's
trey has been scalding hot he's looking
to pick up rbi number 24.
the o2 swinging a line drive over the
drawn in infield base it left field trey
turner
robloz will score in the nationals lead
two to nothing
that one off a curveball right off the
end of the bat and he lines it over the
drawn in
shortstop rbi 24 for turner as the
nationals
extend their lead to two to nothing
[Applause]
this two-strike approach has been so
good this year
suzuki fly ball to right hit it pretty
well first time
oh for three career against charlie
morton
a rocket down the left field corner
let's watch trey
he's heading for third he's coming
around
he circles for the plate and he will
score three nothing gnats on a kurt
suzuki
two out double dugout's going nuts right
now
i love watching trey turner score from
first man
and that stuff we can't see we're on the
road but i want the analytics on his
slides whenever he slides at home plate
i guarantee he goes farther than anybody
else because he's going faster
than anybody else he did hit it would
have thrown him out
one of my favorite words that i overuse
swang gonna miss on the slider
so here we are in the sixth inning max
has a k in each end
and he's showing the full arsenal right
now that was awesome slider
after an awesome change up
for an awesome strikeout he's passed
you darvish tonight and trevor bauer
i think it makes your pitcher make a
perfect pitch
and look at that he's just going to kind
of do a little swinging bunt to right
field
that is beautiful kurt suzuki two for
three
that's some smart fun baseball right
there and then he gets his hands inside
the ball
thinking the right way playing the game
the right way and he's rewarded with a
check swing base it'll take it
so first and third no outs for josh
harrison
here's the 1-0 harrison a line drive to
right field that's going to be a base
hit one hop it's handled by lao
holt will score from third suzuki will
stop at second the nationals have three
straight hits here in the bottom of the
sixth
and now lead at four to nothing rbi
number eight for josh harrison
he has been a key back coming off the
bench and when he's had a chance to
start
he delivers an insurance run for the
nationals here
in the bottom of the sixth inning here's
michael taylor with a bases loaded
chance
four nothing nationals lead
here's the set the o2 swinging a line
drive base hit right field softly head
suzuki scores thames headed for the
plate he's going to score
sliding into third is key boom and
standing at second with a bloop double
to right is michael taylor
an o2 pitch taylor flares a two run
double down the right field line and the
nationals lead at six to nothing
as taylor gets rbis 11 and 12 and
the nationals get some separation here
against the rays
[Applause]
well great night for taylor with the
plays he made in the field
maybe they shouldn't have walked
keyboard
max seven shutout innings
on six base hits eight strikeouts
vintage max
there's a shot by a rosarina pretty well
tagged and he's gonna have another one
home run for rosarina just into the game
and on a one-two pitch
he belts his fourth home run
rosarinda had two home runs yesterday
at tropicana field against miami
davey will bring in his closer daniel
hudson
as i mentioned the tying run comes to
the on deck circle
in joey wendell with randia rosarina
coming up it becomes a save
situation
swing and a miss on a big sweeping
slider
it took about 13 minutes to get that
last
out but the nats get the home stand off
to a good start with a 6-1 win